I've never been to Australia you have it  I've never been I know so many people  from Australia and I wanted to talk to  you because you're amazing and I'm so  excited for you it's incredible that  you've gotten as far as you have with  your obvious physical disadvantages  that's just pure talent there  but my gosh you're amazing man I really  really enjoyed get out and everything  you're doing is fantastic I appreciate  you are wonderful I made a song for you  Thanks  would you mean what do you mean now it's  quick but it's the best I could do in a  short amount of time let's go  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  well that was beautiful you got a thank  you so much I'm just out here  auditioning for everything  [Music]  you